Hello, and welcome to another Unreal Engine training course.
My name's James Burton, and today we're
going to be taking a look at advanced landscape creation.
Just to give you an outline of what the course actually
entails, we'll first be taking a look
at landscape technical details, which
will allow us to essentially understand
what's going on under the hood and what
each section and each component of the landscape tool
actually is.
Then we're going to be taking a look at the landscape
management so that we can actually edit our landscape
and our components.
And throughout the whole course, we'll
be taking a look at how we create the new landscapes,
and also we'll take a look at how to create landscapes
on the high map itself.
So let's go ahead and dive right in and take a look
at some landscape technical details.